Um,
I'm really,
really pleased to be welcoming a professor of Brent Benjamin Bergen here as part
of a toxic Google.
So without further ado,
uh,
I'll,
I'm happy to hand it over to Ben.
So thank you Nancy
[inaudible].
So,
uh,
I'm really thrilled to be back in the homeland.
Um,
and to,
to talk to you about the topic of my latest book.
Now,
as Nancy said,
there will be strong language,
uh,
empirically strong language.
There will be objectively the worst words of the language on the next slide.
So this is a great time.
If you feel like you might be uncomfortable with that,
that sort of thing,
uh,
to conveniently need to slip out and go get some coffee.
Um,
okay,
so human language serves a variety of communicative functions.
The function that we usually think about is conveying information through time
and space,
facts,
descriptions of things.
And that's certainly a thing that language does,
but it does something else as well.
And that's to convey emotion in the hot cognition of immediate feelings.
We need some way to communicate with conspecifics that were angry.
Right now we're frustrated or frightened and this is where profanity thrives.
So what I've tried to do in this book is to take an empirical cognitive science
based approach to what profanity is,
how it works,
how it comes to be,
that way,
how it changes over time,
and importantly what it reveals about our brains,
our social lives and ourselves.
So what I wanted to do today was to give you a brief tour of some of the things
that we learn about profanity and about ourselves,
our brains,
by taking this leap of faith.
And to begin with,
I want to start empirically by asking what precisely profanity is,
where it comes from.
What words do we mean by profanity?
Why are those words profane?
Uh,
and if you were to ask regulatory agencies,
like the FCC for example,
they wouldn't give you a list because they haven't done the leg work.
They don't actually know empirically what people think is offensive language.
But fortunately we do have some evidence from large scale psycholinguistic
studies,
um,
that,
uh,
that tell us broadly what the types of words are that people find profane.
And more specifically exactly which one's a particular group of people find
offensive at a particular time and place.
So let's start locally.
Let's start in California with people in their say twenties.
Um,
what are the worst words of American English according to these people?
So here's a study from about 10 years ago at Ucla that asked a undergrads,
uh,
who would now be in their mid twenties.
Uh,
what are the,
what,
how would you rate a list of words in terms of their offensiveness one word at a
time.
And here are without further ado,
uh,
the words that are worst in English according to these,
these respondents from worst to least bad.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
some,
some things to note for contemporary speakers of,
of American English,
including especially younger ones.
The worst words in the language are predominantly not the words that George
Carlin would have told you 50 years ago are the ones you can't say on
television.
They're a new class of words,
slurs,
in fact,
words that Darryl Gate by insulting a particular social group.
Uh,
but because of their ethnicity or religion,
sex,
sexual orientation,
and so on.
And in fact,
you find that,
uh,
a four letter word that starts withF is actually 13th on the list.
Uh,
we can go down the list a,
if you want and find a whole bunch more offensive words until we get down to a
famous four letter word that starts with s h that doesn't appear to be that
offensive at all compared to the rest of the words in the language.
Now,
when we,
when we compare,
uh,
language taboos across the world's languages,
what we discover is that the types of words that feed into this list are
actually quite representative of the world's languages across the globe.
There are four categories of words that seem to be most reliable in providing
the taboo vocabulary of the language,
um,
that his words relating to,
uh,
religious concepts,
words relating to sex and sexual activities,
words relating to other bodily functions,
the organs that are responsible for those functions,
the actions,
uh,
involved in those functions,
the upkeep of those bodily functions and so on.
Um,
and then finally,
uh,
finally slurs.
And those are the kind of the big four categories that contribute profane
vocabulary.
And if you were to categorize the list of most defensive words in English by
which of these four categories they most properly belong to.
Of course,
there's a little bit of a wiggle room here you would find,
um,
that,
uh,
in English it is indeed the slurs that on average and in specific cases are
judged to be the most profane words of the language.
The most offensive words of the language copulation is also,
uh,
near,
second,
uh,
second best.
And religion doesn't really provide much profane vocabulary to contemporary
American English at all across the world.
Different languages we'll sample differently from each of these columns.
So if you look at Italian,
for example,
the strongest words in Italian known as best mea are,
uh,
basically the formula is this.
You take the word pig and you add it to a religious term and that gives you a
really,
really offensive term.
So protocol,
Madonna or protocol deal really,
really offensive.
Sorry,
Italians.
Um,
in Quebecois French spoken north of the border,
the worst words are these words called Saca,
which are a Catholic liturgical terms like,
um,
uh,
like Taobao hammock or tabernacle or Kelly's,
which is chalice.
And these words are far more offensive than any of the words that we have a on
this list for speakers of chemical off French.
So around the world languages we'll sample differently from these,
from these groups to find their most defensive terminology.
UH,
Russian has recently experienced a big regulatory change.
Uh,
Putin's government,
uh,
has outlawed,
us a set of words known as much,
which are pretty much all drawn from sexual vocabulary and those can now no
longer be used in the arts or media in general.
Um,
so there are differences across the world's languages.
Now you may,
you may be looking at these words and saying,
well,
okay,
this is where the words come from,
but there's a lot that can't be sufficient,
right?
There's lots of words that relate to population or to bodily functions that are
not obscene.
Right?
Words that you would describe when talking with a child in the kindergarten or
when talking,
talking to your doctor for example,
or when labeling these,
uh,
these columns copulation for example,
is not a,
it's not a profane word.
So there must be something else about the words that makes them offensive to
people.
And the first thing that people oftentimes come up with is the length of the
word.
Something about how the word sounds or how it's spelled.
We have this idea in,
uh,
in English that there's something special about four letter words,
right?
And in fact,
if you look empirically at the distribution of four letter words among profane
words compared to what you'd expect on the basis of the distribution in the
language in general,
you do find that there are far more profane four letter words then you would
expect by chance.
And that's true even if you normalize for the frequency of profane words,
but you find something else as well.
It's not just four letter words that are more frequent.
It's also three letter words and five letter words and eight letter words.
And all those differences turned out to be significant.
So,
so what's special about three,
four,
five and hate letter words?
Well,
it has something to do.
If you go back and look at these words,
you can actually,
you can actually start to see the pattern.
The AA letter words are made up of two fourish letter words and why,
why,
and the four and five and three letter words oftentimes sound pretty similar
that they may be spelled with five letters.
But that doesn't mean that they have five distinct sounds.
In fact,
this is an artifact of English orthography being terrible.
So English spelling doesn't look at all like it how it sounds.
It's unlike a rational languages like Spanish for example,
or Indonesian that actually do have a one character per sound,
uh,
dictate well in English,
not so much.
And so in fact,
what's going on with these three and four and five letter words is that English
profane words tend to follow a particular sound pattern.
And that sound pattern is this English syllables come in two varieties.
They're the ones that have continents at the end.
And the ones that have no consonants at the end.
And that makes a big difference for lots of stuff that linguists care about.
The thing that you should care about with respect to this distinction is that
English profane words are far more likely to end with consonants at the end.
They fall into this category over here,
then they are to have no spoken consonants at the end.
And you can come up with maybe five words in English that are arguably profane,
that show up on these lists across languages that people find to be offensive.
Um,
and they're really mostly not that bad,
right?
So,
uh,
who is not the strongest word in the English language,
nor is PE screw jus shows up on some lists.
I think it's the use of Jew as a verb.
So to Jew someone or did you someone down that it's a,
that is judged to be offensive.
Um,
so,
so there's not a lot of profane vocabulary in English that that ends with no
consonants.
There's almost,
all of it ends with continents.
And this differs from the language in general,
which is far more evenly balanced.
When you look at nouns or verbs or frequent words,
infrequent words in general,
uh,
this is a very strange distribution for the sounds of words.
And so,
so you look at this,
this distribution and the,
and this might start to explain the part of why certain words are judged to be
more offensive than others,
even though they might come from the same meaning source.
Um,
but isn't this just a pattern in the lexicon?
Is this just a distributional fact or is this something that's actually active
in the minds of English speakers?
Is this something that you bring to bear when you're exposed to a word?
Do you have this pattern in mind?
Does this template applied to a new word that you're exposed to?
Well,
in order to ask this question,
what we did was we,
uh,
we invented some new words.
We invented words that didn't actually exist in English,
but that were equally likely to,
uh,
to exist in English that had sequences of sounds or sequences of letters that
are coherent with how English works.
But just don't happen to exist.
So,
uh,
that we,
we gave,
we made up words like river and delivered and Sti and steet.
And we ask people to make various judgments about these words.
Uh,
how much does it sound like a word?
And also,
by the way,
how likely do you think this word is to be profane?
And,
uh,
this is what they said.
Uh,
so we had some words that started with just one consonant at the beginning.
Those are these,
and then some that started with s plus a consonant cause that's a nice way to
build more constant contents into the beginnings of words.
And so you see two statistically significant effects here.
Two main effects.
The first is that if you have two consonants at the beginning,
you're going to be judged more profane.
That has higher bars.
Then if you have only one consonant at the beginning,
these two bars are higher than these two bars.
And then the second effect is that the dark bars are higher than the gray bars.
And that's,
uh,
showing that if you have a consonant at the end,
you're judged to be more profound than if you have no consonant spoken consonant
at the end.
And that's true.
Uh,
those,
those two effects are independent of one another.
So it appears to be that people have this template in their minds.
There's expectation that that profane words are going to sound a particular way.
And when exposed to a brand new word,
they bring that to bear.
Now this is not particularly surprising if you've ever watched people invent new
words.
So consider the case of fiction.
So when you have a fictitious language,
say cling on or Dothraki and you have to come up with what is the profane
inventory going to be like without exception English speakers make up words that
follow this heavy consonants at the end pattern.
Moreover,
when people invent new profane words,
and this is happening all the time,
those words overwhelmingly followed this same pattern.
So I have the privilege of teaching at Uc San Diego where I'm able to consult on
a near daily basis with undergraduate students who are aged 18 to 22.
And they know all kinds of things about language and how it's changing that I do
not know.
And uh,
they bring in a new words.
I,
one of the things that I ask them is to surprise me.
Tell me something that I don't know about,
uh,
about how people are using language in your community.
And what you find is that there's a whole host of new group,
new profane words,
uh,
with every new crop of students.
So you might not have heard the word spurg before.
This is a term of abuse for people with Asperger Syndrome.
Um,
you might have heard the word tarred before.
This is an abbreviation for retard.
This is judged by young,
young adults to be one of the most offensive words in the language,
more offensive than the f word.
Um,
uh,
the word milk of the word guilt,
which is a new one that I hadn't heard before.
Um,
so there's a variety of new words,
which not surprisingly,
if people have this pattern in their minds,
follow this heavy consonants at the end syllable pat.
Now why do English profanities tend to sound like this?
Well,
there are a couple of possible explanations.
It could be that at some point in the previous history of the language,
it just happened to be the case that a bunch of profane words sounded like that.
And then over the course of history,
people as they invented new words tended to invent words that sounded like the
ones that they already knew that were profane.
They sort of snowball.
Do you have this accretion by the rich getting richer sort of process?
That's certainly possible.
But it's also possible that there's some,
a reason to the rhyme,
if you will,
that,
um,
that that's a linguist joke by the way.
Um,
that,
um,
that there's,
that there's a specific,
there's a specific reason why this particular pattern.
Now when children start to acquire a language,
the early sounds that they're able to produce are,
uh,
in conformance in conformity with certain patterns.
One thing that's very hard for them to do is to produce a bunch of consonants,
especially at the end of a syllable.
Childlike language tends to reduce syllables to just a consonant and vowel and
often repeats,
if anything.
Um,
so,
so it's possible that these words are tailored to be the type of thing that
sounds least childlike,
not because then children can't produce it,
but just for the sort of the mouth feel of the word,
it feels unlike the type of thing that a child would be likely to say.
And it also sounds unlikely to be something that a child would say.
A final possibility is that it might have something to do with the youth that
you put these words too.
And I first started thinking about this when I saw interviews with people with
Tourette's syndrome.
Now you may or may not be familiar with Tourette's syndrome.
It's an inhibitory control disorder where,
uh,
that's a developmental disorder.
People have trouble controlling ticks,
which are movements usually of the head and neck,
sometimes the upper torso about 10% of the time.
Uh,
they also have a particular symptom known as Copra Lelea,
which is the uncontrollable production of taboo words.
And it so happens that when you ask people how they control this copra Lelea
they often report that what they do is they,
they can't control the beginning of the word.
So one person I saw interviewed for example,
said that his tick was the word cock.
So he couldn't not say that word.
He would be at work,
he would be in public,
you'd be at a,
at a ball game with his kids.
And he just couldn't not say that word,
but he could change the end of the word.
He could just close his mouth.
So cop.
And so his solution was to say cop,
cop,
cop.
And he described the effect as being that people thought that he was a little
bit strange,
but certainly it didn't have the consequence of him not being able to go out in
public anymore.
And,
and so it occurs to me that one of the things that having a bunch of continents
at the end does is it stops the word.
So if what you want to do with profanity is to express a strong emotion and then
be able to quickly curtail the audible illness of that expression,
then maybe it would be useful to have something at the end that's not a vowel
but a consonant.
And there's a little bit of corroborating evidence for this.
The continents that you can stick at the end of a word are not all equal in
their ability to stop sound.
There are some called stop consonants like Po and to and cut that really do just
stop the sound coming out of your mouth.
And if those are the ones that are most likely to occur at the ends of profane
words,
then this is consistent with that explanation.
And in fact,
if you count,
uh,
all English monosyllabic words and you look at the,
the ending continents,
there are about as many stop consonants like Pataka as there are on stop
consonants.
That's in the language in general.
But if you look just at profane English monosyllabic words that are far more
stops than nonstop consequence.
So that's a thing anyway.
Um,
as you look across languages,
you find that this sound pattern doesn't necessarily hold up.
So there are languages,
for example,
that just don't allow continents at the ends of syllables.
Uh,
so Japanese mostly doesn't allow consonants at the ends of syllables except for,
but no others.
A Hawaiian mostly doesn't like consonants at the ends of syllables.
So in those languages you just couldn't have it.
If you turn a well,
we're,
I'm in San Diego,
so if you turn a south,
uh,
you find that Spanish doesn't really have this pattern either.
Most,
uh,
most words in Spanish that are nouns or verbs,
adjectives,
adverbs are a multi syllable words.
So you don't really get one syllable pro profanity in Spanish.
So there are certainly differences across the world,
languages,
so more to be explored here,
but,
but you certainly see that across the world's languages.
Uh,
there is a tendency to have something like profanity drawn from one of these
four categories,
uh,
having certain sound patterns,
although maybe not these specific sound patterns.
And there are few exceptions to the fact of having profanity,
but there are exceptions.
So in some languages or in some cultures I should say,
there's not even a setting.
There's not even a pervasive cultural belief that there's a set of words that we
all agree are the bad words that we shouldn't say in public.
We shouldn't say around kids.
We shouldn't allow kids to say that needed to be bleeped that people should be
punished for.
So for example,
it's long been reported that,
uh,
this is the case in Japan.
So there isn't this sort of social setting that there is a set of words that we
need to,
uh,
we need to make sure that kids are protected from.
So there are lots of ways to insult people in Japanese.
Uh,
there are lots of ways to offend people in Japanese.
You can insult people's ancestors and liken them to animals that really
offensive thing to do.
You can call people ignorant.
You can use the wrong honorific forums.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
those little endings on the ends of,
you know,
verbs and nouns that make it seem like you're talking to someone of low status
rather than high status.
Um,
but specific words that are bad words,
not so much.
If you want to say that someone's,
if you want to insult someone,
you might,
you use the word [inaudible],
um,
to,
to talk about genitalia you might use changing.
Uh,
some people say that.
So,
which literally means excrement,
uh,
is the closest thing that there is to profanity in Japanese.
But you see it in hello kitty videos.
I mean,
it's not,
uh,
it's,
it's clearly not clearly doesn't rise to the level of even even shit,
which as we saw it doesn't,
it doesn't break the top 30.
Um,
so,
uh,
across the world languages,
the idea of profanity is actually built off of something a little bit more than
just just having words belonging to certain tests,
certain domains of experience,
and more than just having words that sound powerful,
there's something else.
There's a cultural setting.
And what we find when we look within a culture across time is that you get the
exact same effect that over the course of the history of a language,
a particular word may enter into being profane.
And then decades or centuries later may no longer be profane.
So it just so happens that,
uh,
if you know someone named Dick,
he's probably 65 years old or older.
And the reason I know that is that I went,
uh,
and I dug into the social security administration naming database,
um,
which has records of every live birth,
recorded in the United States.
And as it turns out,
there was a long period of us history in which children were being given the
given name.
Dick,
not Richard,
these weren't Richards who are nicknamed Dick.
They were actually named Dick and said Dick on their birth certificate.
So what I did was I just counted over on a year by year basis how many dicks
there were and how many risks there were.
Uh,
and uh,
here,
here's the data and sort of speaks for itself.
There was a time when there were lots of dicks and then,
um,
by 1965,
uh,
there were no more decks.
There were risks and there were Richards,
but,
but no more,
no more Dixon.
I actually have a relative named Richard who was born,
uh,
right around here,
who went by Dick until the mid 1990s.
And then we got an email saying,
by the way,
I'm now going by Rick.
And this is a totally rational thing to do for obvious reasons.
This is a word that had accumulated enough,
uh,
enough impact in its secondary,
meaning it's new acquired meaning,
which interestingly seems to have arisen indirectly from a meaning relating to
so.
So Dick First came to me the a riding crop,
like the handle of a riding crop.
You can see how it then would be metaphorically extended to a body parts,
um,
that was maybe shaped similarly.
Um,
but,
uh,
but that change took decades to take effect to the point where people started to
decide that other meaning is just too invasive,
is just too problematic.
When I introduced myself and we see this not just with Dick,
but you can plot the same history with,
uh,
closely related word cock,
which used to only refer to,
um,
uh,
to the rooster,
before the word rooster existed,
then gained a secondary,
meaning.
It gained a meaning relating to well,
they actually have the same thing that Dick did.
And uh,
at that point,
after some centuries of discomfort,
puritanical Americans and the 18th century decided this was not a stable state
of affairs and they really needed another way to describe to call the male of
the chicken.
And they invented a word based on the place that that animal sleeps.
Its sleeps in a roost.
So it is a rooster.
And,
uh,
and that word gained,
gained,
uh,
a familiarity and use in the United States,
although it hasn't caught on in other places in the world.
So you still have,
for example,
Great Britain where a rooster is sort of a funny American word that they know
about it.
Kind of like how,
um,
you know,
like Laurie is for us,
he was like,
whatever,
you guys were ridiculous.
Um,
this is kind of kind of the same thing.
So what we see across words when we look at profane vocabulary is that they,
they follow this pattern that at first,
they're not profane at all,
refer to animals or to people that they gain profane meanings,
that those profane meanings squeeze out the old meanings.
Create an externality of having to invent new words to cover the semantic ground
that is now no longer covered by,
uh,
by the word that's not being used in its original way.
And then eventually these words die out.
So many of the most profane words from English are no longer used.
So if I were to tell you that in Shakespeare's time that the equivalent of the f
word was [inaudible],
you would only know that if you were a Shakespearean scholar.
It comes from an old root,
meaning something like to turn or screw.
We have other words that have followed a similar semantic pattern.
Um,
but,
uh,
but it's completely fallen out of use.
So has tarnation and so has gad,
Zeus and downs.
These are all words that at some point were extremely vulgar.
Uh,
Gad Zoucks comes from God's eyes and it falls into this,
uh,
religious terminology,
but no longer is used at all.
And so this is the general pattern that we observe.
If we're,
if we're to project forward,
we can reasonably assume that the very set of words that are now judged to be
the most offensive ones in the English language within a century certainly will
no longer have the impact that they have.
And it would be surprising if the f word,
for example,
we're still still censored on broadcast television in 20 years.
But at the point at which there's some ambiguity,
there's ample opportunity for double entendre.
And so just because this is a real thing that actually happened,
I wanted to show this.
So right around here in the 1960s,
there was a very famous person whose name was Richard and uh,
and his proponents played on this double meaning to create this actual real,
uh,
political messaging.
It's the type of thing that you could get away with in 1955.
We're 1965 because there was still,
because his name was Dick,
right?
Maybe not.
The thing that you could get away with in 2016 or maybe actually you could have,
well I guess we'll find out in about three weeks.
Um,
okay,
so,
so what makes profanity?
Well,
there's,
there's a whole bunch of that that goes into making prevented the first you have
to have a cultural belief that some words are bad and they,
and you don't have to have that.
You could be Japanese and not have that cultural belief.
Second,
you have to apply that belief to specific words,
which are most likely to be drawn from certain categories of meaning and they
make may pattern together and sound.
And then in order for that belief system to be inserted into people's brains,
there has to be some system for reinforcing it.
So there has to be some system of punishment.
Censorship.
Ironically,
the punishment,
the soap in the mouth,
the bleeping on the,
on television,
that is exactly what makes those specific words have the taboos that they have.
It is the thing that recreates that belief system for each new generation of
speakers of the language.
Now I wanted to talk to you not just about what profanity is and sort of some of
the science of like what we know about it,
but also what it uniquely reveals about our brains.
And so that's what I wanted to turn to next.
There are certain facts about how profanity is used that differ from the rest of
language.
Profanity is emotional.
It evokes emotions and other people.
It is inhibited.
It is the type of thing that you know,
that you're not supposed to say in certain circumstances.
And as a consequence,
it uses different brain systems from the rest of language.
And I'm going to show you now two kinds of things that we learn about how our
brains compute language on the basis of this.
A set of facts to the first has to do with speech.
Every speech is peppered with errors.
I've tried to not produce many now,
but in fact,
people produce roughly and error every thousand words.
It's a lot.
Um,
in particular it's been believed for a long time,
uh,
that the speech errors may reflect,
thoughts that people have that they are not consciously or did Eric consciously
trying to suppress.
And if this is true,
then we might expect to find that.
Repress thoughts produce more taboo errors,
then non taboo errors,
all things being equal.
And certainly we tend to notice when people make speech errors that are vulgar,
right?
So here are two examples.
This is if you watch the news enough live news,
you'll get this,
um,
examples like this.
I hope that the audio works here
soon.
67 Nasser going to share with your partner in me in the mood for a little rooms
and we've been sued in the Hannukah Hall Haig Long Food Truck Food truck.
That's what I meant to say is old I five lunch truck is here for that.
Okay.
Food truck that says,
okay,
here's another example.
I mean you could find that
it's a sausage competition that I judge.
Oh,
like sausage eating.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Kayla Cuevas and local sausage makers,
they all make their best and they enter it.
I bet.
If delicious.
It is February 9th,
7:00 PM adds up.
Prairieland Park tickets are only $25.
It's for charity.
And uh,
you can get,
uh,
tickets online ad pick dick pic.
Oh,
well you're thinking about thoughts
about sausage.
Thank goodness that was ridiculous.
We were not drinking wine today.
No,
we were now looking really good event.
It is kicking a Cabasa.
So go to pick a dick.
Okay,
so,
so these are,
these are the ones you feel sorry for her.
Right?
And she probably enjoyed the wine.
But these are,
these are,
these are the,
these are the errors that we notice,
of course,
because if she said,
uh,
pick a kick,
it would,
no one would care.
Right?
It wouldn't make a difference.
It doesn't violate a social expectation about behavior,
for example,
on broadcast television.
But when you actually look,
when you,
when you do the controlled experiment,
I won't give you the details,
but when you create conditions for people to produce errors that are either
taboo errors or like those or neutral errors that don't produce any taboo
language at all,
what you find,
there've been a variety of studies are showing you the,
the the first two,
but data hold up for and have held up for nearly 40 years.
Um,
you find that people are far more likely,
they make,
uh,
many times more depending on the study to make many times more neutral errors
than taboo errors.
And that's actually revealing because why would you be able to avoid making
errors when the error would be taboo?
Well,
the interpretation and the thing that we've learned about language and the brain
from looking at this,
these taboo areas specifically is that in the cases when it would make them win,
there would be the most damage to making an error because it would be a taboo
word coming out.
Those are the conditions under which you avoid making errors,
which implicates a,
an internal self monitoring system.
And there's a whole bunch of research that's grown up around this idea that
perhaps when you're planning to produce speech,
when you're activating those words in some grammatical organisation and you're
going to speak them,
that you do a little sanity check,
you run an internal simulation and internal model of what it's going to be like
to say those words.
And in the case where there's something bad coming down the pike,
you pull the lever and stop the assembly line.
And we actually know now by comparing cases where people have,
um,
are induced to make errors that are,
would be profane,
uh,
like,
hit shed.
Okay.
If you switch the first sounds of hit shed,
it would be taboo if you switch.
The first sounds of hit said it would not be.
So if you compare what happens in PR in a person's brain when they successfully
avoid making an error on the taboo ones versus the neutral ones,
you find that this is the part of the brain right here that's doing more work,
avoiding making a taboo error.
It's a particular part of the brain known as the right inferior frontal gyrus.
That's part of a system specifically responsible for wait for it inhibitory
control.
It's responsible for,
you know when you're sitting at a light and it turns green and you're about to
go and then all of a sudden the light changes.
Maybe there's a firetruck coming from the other direction and it did that
magical blinking thing where it changes the lights.
So your ability to not do something to inhibit the execution of that action.
That's what the right inferior frontal gyrus is implicated in.
It does it in general when you're moving around in the world and it does it
specifically when you're avoiding producing profane language,
and we can see this in people's behavior as well.
So people are suppressing their trying to inhibit producing profane words in
tasks like this.
So this is a a task notice picture,
word interference.
If you give people a a picture and say,
name that picture,
what is this?
A picture of as quickly as possible and then measure how long it takes them to
say what the name of that thing is and then prince and irrelevant word over it.
You find that as long as the word doesn't have similarity in sound or meaning,
it doesn't interfere with naming the word with saying the word dog.
Um,
but what happens when you give them a word that they had that they're supposed
to ignore,
that they have more trouble ignoring?
Well,
you find that saying the word dog in this circumstance takes people a
significantly longer.
The taboo distractors slows people down for to say the word dog.
And the reason for that is because they are activating this inhibitory control
mechanism there bought their brain is saying,
don't say that word,
and it slows down the production of any word.
The second major finding that I wanted to talk about with respect to the brain
has to do with the originators in the brain.
Those circuits that are responsible for producing language.
Now,
if you've taken an introductory psychology class or linguistics,
maybe even you will have learned that in almost all people,
there are language centers housed in the left hemisphere of the brain,
specifically responsible for particular language functions,
broke his area,
articulates words or lines them up or something.
Vernac his area is responsible for word meaning.
Um,
primary auditory cortex is responsible for hearing the sounds that then are
interpreted in terms of words.
And there's a lot of truth to all of this.
The thing is that when people have damage to these different parts of the brain,
they have damage to the specific fund functions that those parts of the brain
are supposed to be involved with.
With some exceptions.
And we've known this for a 150 years that one of the first scientists to study,
um,
the incapacitation of language due to brain damage was or known as Aphasia,
uh,
was uh,
a researcher and physician known as Jacques Florida.
Uh,
he was arguably the founder of neuro linguistics.
He was born in 1773.
He was trained in Montpellier,
and at the age of 52,
he suffered a debilitating stroke.
And that stroke left him basically unable to speak,
but he recovered.
And he began to study people who had similar conditions,
who had had some sort of brain damage leading to an inability to produce
language.
And his most famous case was a parish priest,
a man of the cloth who had a stroke,
lost his ability to speak entirely,
had no ability to speak with the exception of two words.
And those two words were the French word,
[inaudible],
which means I or me.
And the second was as a Lord,
Thou wrote the most forceful oaths of the tongue,
which begins with an f in which our dictionaries have never dared to print.
The French F word starts with the same letter as the English effort as it by,
by,
by coincidence.
Um,
and so this is now common knowledge among the physiologists that people who have
damage to Broca's area.
We'll lose language in general,
but not necessarily swearing.
Many people who lose the ability to produce language in general.
And this is due to,
uh,
due to traumatic brain injury due to stroke.
Like in these cases,
um,
Alzheimer's disease can cause Aphasia as well.
A variety of different causes can lead to this same syndrome.
People will,
uh,
so,
patients,
for example,
we'll be looking at a picture of a dog and a cat and there's supposed to say the
dog is chasing the cat and they can't say the dog is chasing the cat.
So they'll swear.
Um,
the most extreme example is from people who,
uh,
for medical reasons had to have their entire left hemisphere removed.
So,
um,
the most convincing case is,
uh,
a patient known as EEC.
He was 47 years old,
right handed man,
left lateralized for language,
and he had severe symptoms,
um,
from a,
a substantial left hemisphere tumor on his frontal lobe.
So over Broca's area,
um,
the tumor was removed but was determined to be malignant.
And so his,
uh,
doctors decided to remove the entire,
hemisphere or radical left hemispherectomy.
And,
uh,
so what,
what happened?
What happened in the case of his language?
Well,
this is what happened.
According to his doctor after his entire left hemisphere who was removed at the
age of 47,
his attempts to,
to reply to questions immediately after operation were totally unsuccessful.
He would open his mouth and other isolated words,
and after apparently struggling to organize words for meaningful speech,
recognized his inability and would utter expletives or short emotional phrases
like God dammit,
expletives and curses were well articulated and clearly understandable.
It doesn't have language except when he's swearing due to profanity.
Or do you do frustration?
Do this strong emotional states.
Now,
what could possibly be the part of the brain that can support language support,
emotional,
uh,
communication if the entire left hemisphere is removed?
Well,
we know because of specific case studies like this one.
So this is the case of a particular individual who is a bilingual French,
uh,
Hebrew speaker,
75 years old,
right handed.
He had a stroke and after his stroke he was unable to swear all of his language
was preserved except for swearing.
And a couple of other things.
He could not provide the correct expletive for situations described to him,
nor he could he complete a curse.
Now,
if you know people who speak French or people who speak Hebrew,
this is,
uh,
an,
an absolutely strange state of affairs not to be able to curse.
Um,
and,
and so here's the payoff.
Where did this particular subject,
this particular patient,
where did he have brain damage from his stroke?
He had damage and the right hemisphere of his brain in a place called the Basal
Ganglia.
The Basal Ganglia are,
uh,
a part of the limbic system,
which is responsible for emotion regulation.
The Basal Ganglia in particular seem to be responsible for deciding what actions
to perform and what actions to not specifically perform on the basis of an
emotional state.
So I'm angry.
Should I fight or flight?
I'm angry.
Should I say something?
If so,
what should I say?
That sort of thing.
Or should I not say anything at all?
That appears to be what the Basal Ganglia do.
And so it appears that we have a second system that can produce vocalizations
and there's some corroborating evidence again from Tourette's syndrome,
which I mentioned earlier,
when people have coper Lelea it can be through Tourette's syndrome,
but other sorts of diseases produce it as well.
Um,
you,
when you have corporate Lelea,
these are the types of words that you,
that you are unable to suppress saying they look a lot like the first list that
we saw in fact and what brain mechanisms are impaired in Tourette's syndrome.
That's right.
The Basil Ganglia,
Basal Ganglia are different in people who have developmental Tourette Syndrome,
then people who are a neuro-typical.
So what we learned from this is that there are actually multiple vocalization in
humans.
There's one pathway,
the one over here on your left that's in blue that doesn't really involve all
these smart,
evolutionarily new cortical systems that we think are the things that evolved
that allow us to do language instead.
This system is a sort of a shortcut that we share with other mammals.
And in fact,
um,
even other vertebrates,
it's a system for vocalizing that other primates,
for example,
use when they're,
uh,
expressing fear or identifying a Predator that's in their environment.
On the other side in red,
you have the system.
Um,
that is our new,
our new system.
Um,
so we have,
we have two capacities for language,
one for reflexive,
automatic emotional language and another for rational,
cerebral,
intentional communication,
a of ideas.
And again,
we wouldn't know about this,
this binary system of pathways,
these two pathways if it weren't for profane language.
So profanity works differently from the rest of language.
It sounds different.
It changes differently over time.
It's processed differently in the brain.
There are significant gains to be made in the science of language by looking at
profanity.
But first we have to overcome the stigmas associated with these most powerful
words of our language.
I'd like to thank you now and then welcome.
Any questions that you have?
Thanks a lot.
I'm just curious,
what is the most long or complicated profane word?
The longest and most complicated profane word is surely one in German,
but,
uh,
so German speakers help me out here.
Um,
uh,
so,
um,
in English,
uh,
I don't know you,
so there is a lot of productive use of profanity and there are lots of these
parts of words that you can add on to other parts to make bigger ones.
I couldn't hazard a guess,
but um,
but I would guess it would be in a language like German that creates words that
have lots of little bits until it probably has something to do with what we're
all sort of compounds.
That's right.
They would be compound words.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
All right.
Thank you for your talk.
Um,
is there any difference between um,
like taboo words versus um,
like explicative,
uh,
like curse words?
So,
uh,
in the former sense where it's more thought out methodical to installed somebody
whose ancestor or something like that.
And the latter being,
I want to just get my emotion out.
Can I ask people about their feelings about words?
And you can get some dissociations between the following two questions.
How offensive is it?
Is this word to you personally?
How offensive is it versus how taboo do you think it is in the culture?
And there's some words that differ and you find interesting differences in,
um,
for example,
uh,
across,
across genders.
Um,
there are certain words that,
for example,
women will find very offensive but not judged to be that taboo and vice versa.
Um,
that men don't seem to have the same,
the same sensitivity too.
So those two things do certainly dissociate.
And in fact,
if you look at the,
if you look at the w,
the words that are produced during a copra Lelea,
they're actually more properly described as,
as taboo,
then profane.
And the reason that I say that is when you look at corporate Lelea in Japan
where they just don't have that,
you know,
that set of,
of,
of profane words,
the words that come out are often words describing,
they can be like childlike words for bodily functions or for sex.
Oregon's,
um,
or words describing,
visual characteristics of a person like fat or you know,
dark or,
you know,
whatever,
whatever it is that they're not supposed to be saying about how,
how another person looks,
those are taboo acts of talking,
even if the word itself isn't,
isn't offensive.
So yeah,
the,
to do kind of dissociate
when you say,
uh,
we have this a secondary mechanism which has a different pathway,
how does that then work with the Japanese for example?
Yeah.
So you,
you mentioned that,
that,
I mean there's almost no,
no words there.
And then my second question is,
uh,
what would be the difference then a few like saying go fuck yourself versus,
you know,
like go calculate yourself.
Ah,
what would be the difference in,
in,
in terms of the brain mechanisms underlying it?
Yeah.
Okay.
So we don't know what happens in the brains of Japanese speakers when they do
whatever is most closely equivalent.
We do know that the,
if you take people,
run them through an Fmri machine and have them either square or produce minced
oaths.
So,
uh,
not fucked,
but frick,
uh,
not,
not shit,
but shoot,
um,
you don't get anything like the same sort of a limbic system activation.
Um,
so,
uh,
in English speakers,
those alternatives don't count.
Um,
we don't know what happens with Japanese speakers when they use words that are
kind of equivalent to the minced oaths that are kind of like,
oh darn.
Um,
it's possible that something,
it could go either way,
a empirical question.
Um,
but we know that the physiology is different.
So when you expose people to,
to strong profane words,
uh,
it triggers this,
fight or flight response.
This,
uh,
this sympathetic nervous system response where,
you know,
adrenaline starts pumping,
heart rate increases,
blood flows to the extremities,
pupils dilate,
you get,
you know,
narrowed vision and you're ready to,
ready to react.
That works.
That doesn't work for Japanese speakers with the pseudo profanities that you
could use things like so and so on.
Um,
so there's a good reason to believe that their brain's probably don't do that
thing.
Now their brains would do that for other sorts of emotional vocalizations.
So,
uh,
I imagined that when sumo wrestlers,
you know,
do,
they're like yelling at each other thing,
there's probably,
if,
if it's emotional for,
they're probably activating that,
that,
that vocalization circuit.
It's not language,
but it's kind of that same thing.
I guess what I'm asking is,
uh,
you know,
like if they would drop it,
break on their toe rights.
Yeah.
Does it say,
yeah.
Yeah.
Like I said,
we just,
we just don't know if they were just vocalize,
think there were a reaction.
I mean,
even non verbal.
Yeah.
Verbal stuff comes out.
It's just not profanity per se.
So it's either non-linguistic it's like the equivalent of owl,
um,
or it's stuff that is the equivalent of darn.
Um,
and so,
yeah,
what we don't know is what's happening in the brain.
And in the latter case,
uh,
you had another question
was the difference between,
uh,
go fuck yourselves.
Um,
go copulate yourselves.
Oh yeah.
Well for sure.
Yet huge difference.
So the,
uh,
so the second has to be computed,
compositionally through that left hemisphere is system of critical operations.
Um,
the go fuck yourself could,
could actually happen either way.
You could be deliberating Kekelik how am I most going to needle this person?
Like what is the word that is most likely to get this person riled up to get
into this person's skin?
I'm going to say go fuck yourself.
Right?
You could calculate that entirely rationally,
uh,
cortically or it could be produced via hot cognition.
So that actually has two ways to produce it,
which is,
which is the really interesting thing.
It's not the profanity is just generated one place and the rest of languages
generated something somewhere else.
It's that for a particular biological purpose you have,
you have one way to generate the exact same words that you can generate through
a different a assembly line.
I think it's really interesting to hear about,
um,
the side of the speaker,
like why people cost or why they swear.
Like it seems like it's like a release almost in terms of trying to get those
emotions out like you said.
Um,
but I'm wondering,
have you done studies on the other side,
the recipient side of people in the room with you?
If you swear like Joseph's morning in a meeting,
someone like said the swear word and everyone like broke out laughing and I find
that to be like a common occurrence and I wonder is that like why does that
happen?
Why do people,
do people swear to get that kind of reaction?
And I think of like musical artists as well,
like rappers and hip hop artists.
Um,
but yeah,
just want to get your take on that.
Yes,
great question.
There has been a lot of a descriptive work trying to characterize why it is that
people respond differently in different contexts to the same words.
So why does a set of words,
when produced by a comedian,
uh,
when that you're watching,
you've decided to go watch that comedian,
you know,
that he works or she works blue,
right?
You know that it's Ali Wong,
you know that it's going to be,
it's going to be really vulgar.
You're prepared for it.
She could say a set of things that when produced by say,
a political candidate,
um,
would have a totally different,
uh,
physiological response in you.
Um,
a large part of it has to do with our expectations going in and particularly the
social dynamics at play.
So people use profanity to cement social relations to demonstrate that this is
an informal situation.
They use it to be funding,
uh,
to break the ice.
They use it to display power.
So if,
uh,
if I'm the boss,
then I can,
I can show that I'm the boss,
but cause I can use casual language,
I can use profanity.
Whereas the person who is not the boss might not get away with that same type of
language and might be a judge to be.
That person might be thought to be misjudging the situation if they think that
they can get away with using the same language.
So there's a lot of social work that people do,
not social work,
but social work that people do with,
uh,
with profanity.
And,
uh,
we are constantly calculating what we,
what we can get away with and what the consequences of our linguistic actions
are going to be.
You know,
you know,
if you've worked in a place for a long time with a particular set of people,
what the rules are,
who's going to be offended by what.
And so those are oftentimes the places that people feel most comfortable,
comfortable using profanity,
um,
to do a variety of things like seem funny,
like break the ice,
like a cement social relations in new situations.
Now I'm,
you know,
my first day on the job,
that's probably not going to be a goto because you haven't,
you haven't taken the temperature of the environment yet.
Right?
So,
uh,
there's a lot of evidence that in workplaces,
people use profanity,
uh,
for lots of different functions.
Um,
and that in general,
people who use profanity or judged to be more accessible,
more informal and more powerful,
but depending on the power structure,
it could be that the judge to be brutish or they could be judged to be,
um,
out of touch or inconsiderate or out of control.
So again,
it's all about,
you know,
I'm not a sociologist,
but it's really about the social dynamics at play.
What do you feel about the common processes?
Trying to steer children towards the less profane words,
you know,
shoot instead of,
yeah,
well,
I mean it totally works every time,
right?
Because if I don't sweat them,
they're just not going to learn it.
Right?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
so this is something that I have thought a lot about have a two year old at
home.
And uh,
so this is a conscious decision that you have to make as,
as an adult around kids.
You have to decide how you want to,
how you want to expose them to all of these complexities that we've just been
talking about,
about the social world.
And,
uh,
it's certainly the case that there's certain types of language that can cause
harm to children.
Verbal abuse,
calling children,
worthless,
insulting them,
threatening them.
That's all stuff that's known to cause harm.
Slurs are known to cause harm in kids.
Kids who,
so kids in middle school who are called by homophobic slurs report as a
correlational studies because he can't do this experimentally,
obviously.
Um,
but they report rate increases in depression,
anxiety,
detachment from school.
There's lots of stuff that's not good to have around kids linguistically,
but there's no evidence that just the fleeting expletive because you tripped
over a kitty gate in the middle of the night.
Um,
is the type of thing that will cause harm to a child.
What will cause harm to a child is if they don't know that using these words in
certain circumstances is going to have consequences for them.
And so there are lots of ways that you can teach them what the consequences are
going to be.
My preferred method is to explain what the consequences are going to be.
Um,
you know,
kids,
uh,
do a lot of social learning when you potty train.
I have a lot of familiarity with this.
When you potty train a two year old,
for example,
most of the learning is about there are certain places and times for particular
activities and lots of other places and times that those activities are
inappropriate,
like on the couch or in the middle of kindergarten,
preschool or,
um,
and that's a thing that a two year old can learn and a two year old can learn
that this is a language that I use at home and I use this other language because
I'm bilingual at school.
Kids can learn that.
And so I don't see any reason that kids can't also learn that this is a word
that daddy uses when he's upset.
It's not a bad word and daddy's not bad for using it.
He's not a bad person.
But if you use this word at school,
expect that some people might not like it and there might be consequences.
Okay,
go ahead and explore,
you know,
do what you're gonna do.
Uh,
you know,
that,
that's my,
that's that,
that's my general view of what the literature tells us best practices ought to
be.
I'm,
uh,
coming up with a sort of linguists direction as I'm sure you know,
I'm interested in sort of,
it seems like there's,
even from the neural level,
there's kind of two things you could be probing.
There's the,
the things that they have this inhibitory response,
which I see,
think it's really your,
your core category.
Those are the forbidden words,
right?
And you have a constant monitor to try to prevent yourself from producing those.
And when you do produce them,
you,
you have to inhibit the inhibition,
so to speak.
Um,
but then there's this other category of sort of limbically produced words,
right.
Um,
are those,
are those really exactly the same?
Or the words like,
ouch.
Get used in like left brain removed people.
Yeah.
So they do.
That's what I was going to say is there's,
there's an exclusive category.
Yup.
There's six laminators will often be preserved to interjections are often
presented things like,
uh,
oh no.
Or,
um,
I mean,
uh,
or out she had,
those will oftentimes be preserved in brokers or global aphasia.
Um,
not always,
uh,
but they,
but they often are and they seem to be exactly what you're describing.
It's,
I'm in an emotional state,
I'm producing language.
Uh,
this is going to come out.
So it seems to be generated by a different system for sure.
So as you became immersed in this work,
did you find your personal production rate of expletives increase?
And if so,
what did you do to fix that?
As Nancy said,
it was impossible that it could increase,
well increased in a way because now I'm talking about all these words all the
time.
So it increased in professional context.
Um,
no.
If anything,
I think it decreases because the,
okay,
there's this effect,
right?
As you get exposed to these words over and over and over and over and over,
they started to lose their impact a little bit.
This is kind of what's happening with young people and the democratization of
media.
So 20 years ago when you only ever got exposed to language in media that was
filtered through some sensor,
you didn't hear these words much.
Now,
uh,
you know,
the media is in your pocket and uh,
directly from someone's thumbs to your eyes,
you get,
uh,
you get a stream of language.
And if you're playing video games before,
you know,
network of games before breakfast,
you'll get a,
you know,
a hundred f words before,
um,
before you go to school.
So,
so kids are exposed to a lot more of this.
And as a consequence,
I think that's,
that's part of the reason that you get this consequence,
which is that those run of the mill profane words start to creep down the list.
The F word isn't judged to be that bad anymore by,
um,
by digital natives.
So that the same has happened to me that you,
that I,
uh,
in a way,
these words just don't really do much for me anymore.
Sorry Nancy.
Thank you for the bad.
Our stock.
So it appears that repeated exposure decreases the impact of profanities.
So I have one or two questions depending on your answer.
The first question,
I might have a second one.
So the first question is,
would English speaking society's be better off or worse off if profanities just
lost their impact or disappear from the language?
Somehow they would be different off.
I mean,
there would be a little bit more like France.
So,
so in France there are profane words that are bad words,
uh,
but they're not as bad as they are here.
So you don't get them to see them censored or bleeped on,
uh,
on daily television that you could see them on the evening news broadcasts,
you could see them around kids,
you could see them produced by kids.
Even the strongest words,
even that,
that,
that f word that our dictionaries have not seen fit to print.
Um,
I have,
I saw the president of the republic say it on the floor of the Senate.
Um,
so,
uh,
you might end up with something like that where,
yeah,
you can use the words,
they just have a little bit less social cache and so they do a little bit less
emotional work.
That's what you would end up with,
I think.
Okay.
So at least we will unemployed a few sensors,
some perhaps seven,
do something more productive with their lives.
So the second question is,
um,
as you know,
Google has,
um,
made some attempts at d deradicalizing Muslim terrorists by showing certain
neutral search results when they search for radical materials.
So it's a form of mind influence.
If you were at Google and had some control over this,
what would you do to reduce the impact of profanities?
Well,
I mean,
you're leading me down the path of saying,
well,
you should just show more of it,
right?
Um,
but I think that you,
what you need to do is show it in specifically,
uh,
low emotional arousal contexts.
So if it's a,
the reason that we think these words are bad is because early in life we saw
them used or heard them be used in strongly emotional contexts,
right?
Someone was really frustrated.
Someone was in experiencing strong pain or it was really angry or really
excited.
We use them and we got a really strong emotional reaction,
right?
Those,
that emotional substance is what makes us think that they are powerful words.
And that we have internalized,
we've associated because we're heavy and learners,
and now we,
uh,
now we can't help but have that emotional response when we're presented with
that word.
However,
the De contextualized presentation,
you know,
you see a list of words and study them over and over and over,
that has no reinforcing emotional content.
And so I guess you would have to,
if you really wanted to deescalate the emotional value of those words,
they would need to be presented in an emotional context.
So I wouldn't show,
I wouldn't show those words used in strident political discourse,
for example.
Um,
or in,
um,
in other sorts of highly emotional context.
I would show them in lists of words or in analysis context or some sort of like
really boring,
mundane,
anodyne place,
I guess.
But,
you know,
I'm not an engineer,
so that probably wouldn't work.
I don't know.
Thank you so much.
Pleasure to talk to you.